based on a true story dear everyone
please subscribe to my new channel
YouTube I think I'm about to hit three
sub soon please subscribe and also
please don't hate beets dear fans thanks
for 5 subs I think I might post my first
video soon dear fans please join my new
sniper clan Falcon lovers ex ex ex ex ex
ex ex only if you're a pro first video
coming up next week see you there Nick
nice people
dear Falcon lovers I set up t-shirts and
PayPal's link is on here don't hate and
donate peace dear Falcon lovers sorry
for delays no video because my neck
hurts now
thanks for understand hashtag pray for
Falcon loads neck dear Falcon lovers I
just posted my video on my channel
please like favorite subscribe and
subscribe also leave a comment and
subscribe also thumbs up this video and
please forget to subscribe thank you
also don't hate sorry for self
advertising don't hate my videos haters
dear Falco lovers mom says to have the
chicken parts I have yellow and brown
rashes over my body
maybe this will improve the noscopes who
knows
Falcon lovers today I got noscope buy a
face clan member go check out montage on
main channel not Falcon blogs or falcon
iphone blogs or falcon gaming blogs or
falcon gaming gaming it will make your
wet my brother told me that I'm
more of a dog person myself you should
like it and go there peace dear Falcon
lovers we lost one of our own subs today
we only 3 subs now my brother unsubbed
also I don't understand why maybe you
know like my
videos maybe your hater sad face
dear Farkle lovers let's all come clear
to me now the rashes the neck pain the
lack of no scopez I finally understand
the truth of the situation I'm a giraffe
I belong in the plain white fields of
Africa with my people in sunshine I will
shine possibly get noscoped this is my
final you to comment peace forever
also forget to subscribe Vocaloid ex ex
ex ex